[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام هل ترك النظام
السوري تهمه الا والصقها بالثوار
السوريين الم يصفهم في البدايه بالمندسين
ثم بال
ثم بالعصابات المسلحه ثم بالسلفيين واليوم
يصفهم بالارهابيين
القاعديين اليست الثوره السوريه اكبر بالف
مره من الجماعات الجهاديه التي يشيطن
النظام الا يشكل الجيش الحر السواد الاعظم
من المقاتلين وكلهم
بعثيون وعددهم بعشرات الالوف هل يزيد عدد
جبهه النصره على 3000 مقاتل وحتى لو كان
هناك جهاديون في سوريا ببضعه عشرات فلماذا
التركيز عليهم وتجاهل عشرات الالوف من
الايرانيين والعراقيين وحزب الله هل
المقاتلون السنه ارهابيون ومقاتلو حزب
الله حملان وديعه
وحضاري ثم اليس الكثير من الجماعات
الجهاديه من صنيعه النظام السوري وايران
من كان ينظمهم ويرسلهم الى العراق متى
يتوقف النظام السوري عن تخويف الاقليات
والخارج
بالبعبوص نع يتساءل
اخر لكن في المقابل الم تاخذ الثوره
السوريه طابعا جهاديا بدليل ان اقوى
المقاتلين على الارض
جهاديون الم تعلن جبهه النصره مبايعتها
لزعيم تنظيم القاعده ايمن الظواهري اليس
من حق النظام السوري ان يقول للعالم الان
انه يواجه جماعات ارهابيه معروفه للعالم
اجمع اليس من حقه ان يقول ان الصراع في
سوريا بين دوله علمانيه وجماعات ارهابيه
الا يسيطر امراء الحرب على العديد من
المناطق في سوريا اليس كل الشعارات التي
يرفعها الثوار السوريون جهاديه اسلاميه هل
صام الشعب السوري دهرا كي يفطر على دوله
طالبان ظلاميه كيف يتهمون النظام السوري
باخراج الجهاديين من سجونه بينما هم اقوى
من يقاتلونه اسئله اطرحها على الهواء
مباشره على مدير الاعلام السابق في دار
الافتاء السوريه السيد عبد الجليل السعيد
والخبير في الجماعات الاسلاميه السيد احمد
موصلي نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تعتقد ان النظام السوري يضخم
العنصر الاسلاميه في الثوره السوريه
لتشويه الثوره وتخويف الاقليات
88.8 نعم 11.2 لا سيد عبد الجليل السعيد
لو بدات معك بهذه النتيجه ما الذي يجعل
هذه النسبه الكبيره
88% يعتقدون ان النظام السوري يحاول شيطنه
الثوره السوريه منذ اللحظه الاولى
بتصويرها على انها بعبع اسلامي سياكل وكذا
وكذا نفس اللعبه بتاع الثمانينات نفس
الاكاذيب اسلاميين اسلاميين وانه
الاسلاميين سياكل سوريا ولم يخرب سوريا
غير هو كما يقولون لك في البدايه بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم بطبيعه الحال الثوره
السوريه هي ثوره معجزه بكل تفاصيلها لست
هنا اسوق عبارات انما اقول دلائل النظام
السوري حينما نظر الى ان المنشقين
العسكريين و هم قوام الجيش الحر وهم
السواد الاعظم من الثوار كم نسبتهم بداوا
ياخذون المكانه النسبه كبيره ولربما
تتجاوز ال 90% وانا هنا لا اكون كما يقال
ارمي كلاما جزافا خذ على سبيل المثال هيئه
الاركان التي ينضبط تحتها غالبيه الجيش
الحر حتى الان جبهه تحرير سوريا الاسلاميه
الجبهه السوريه الاسلاميه هيئه الدروع
الكتائب القبليه المقاتله اين هذا كله مما
يتكلم عنه النظام من ان العنصر الاسلامي
او حتى العنصر الذي يغلب عليه التطرف كما
يصف طبعا وانا هنا لست اتيا لاحام عن جبهه
النصره فجب النصره عملها يدل عليها ولا
تحتاج الى مدافعين عنها جبهه النصره عملت
مع السوريين وهي جزء عظيم من الثوره
السوريه ولكنها ليست السواد الاعظم من
الشعب السوري وليست السواد الاعظم من
المقاتلين السوريين لذلك تتفق بنيه وفطره
الناس الذين صوتوا مع ما يجدونه على الارض
حين ينزلون فثوره التي خرجت من المساجد
ونادت بالحريه انظر الى هذه المعادله
دكتور فيصل خرج الناس من المساجد التي هي
بيوت الله لينادى بالحريه التي تنشد دوله
مدنيه يسود فيها العدل ولا يسود فيها
الظلم الذي ينتجه النظام وينتج كل كل يوم
الاف والاف الالوان من العذابات الذي التي
يذوقها السوريون طيب بس خلينا نثبت هذه
النقطه قبل ان انتقل للدكتور المصلي يعني
تريد ان تقول لي انه الجماعات الاسلاميه
المتطرفه التي يحاول النظام السوري تخويف
الاقل
والعالم الخارجي بها لا تشكل سوى خمسه او
جزء يسير جدا من الثوره السوريه والباقي
هم الجيش الحر ومعظمهم بعثيون يعني بالامس
بعثيون صاروا الان سلفيون دكتور عمر
الثوره السوريه حتى الان تجاوز السنتين
خلينا بس نرجع الى الحقائق بشيء من
المصداقيه بثينه شعبان خرجت في الشهر
الرابع وهي تتحدث عن جماعات متطرفه النظام
السوري صور الشيخ
الصياصنة صوره على انه زعيم الارهابيين
وانه يصعد على المنبر في 28/4 ويقول للناس
المال موجود اذا الهوليوديه النظاميه في
استديوهات علي مملوك للانتاج والتوزيع
الفني كانت موجوده منذ البدايه والنظام
عرف انه لا التوزيع الفني شو قصدك صديقي
النظام الذي يعني تريد ان تقول ل الجماعات
الاسلاميه المتطرفه صناعه المخابرات
السوريه صديقي العزيز من صنع ابو عدس وصنع
ابو القعقاع لا يعجز ان يصنع لك في مخيله
الشعوب الاف والاف المتطرفين نظام ابو عدس
هذا الذي اخرج لنا ابو عدس بفيديو بعد
مقتل الحرير رحمه الله الا يستطيع اليوم
ان يقول لك ان المتطرفين يملؤون الثوره
السوريه نظام ابو القعقاع الذي بعثه
والبسه البزه الجهاديه وطلب منه ان يجيش
الناس للقتال في العراق المالكي صديقهم
الم يقل ان النظام السوري استاذ في
الارهاب وارسل ذلك الى الامم المتحده اي
تطرف يتحدثون عن و ماذا فعلوا بالقعقاع
بعد ما عمل الان حينما انتهت مهمته لم
يبقى لهم الا ان يقتلوه فقتلوه بدم بارد
وكان انذاك يتولى منصبا رسميا في البلاد
وجنازته لم يزد حاضرها من المسؤوليين
الرسميين الا بضعه عشرات نعم سيد دكتور
سمعت هذا الكلام انه النظام يحاول ان يضخم
ويبالغ النصره والقاعده كل ذلك لكي يبقى
في السلطه كل ذلك كي يخوف السوريين يخوف
الاقليات يخوف العالم الخارجي اما انا او
القاعده مع انه ليس هناك لا قاعده والذين
يقاتلون يعدون يعني طارت اخر احصائيه
امريكيه واسرائيليه النصره 3000 مقابل
اكثر من 100000 كيف ترد اولا يعني البلش
بالاستفتاء محل ما بدا لا شك انه الضخ
الاعلامي من وسائل اعلاميه كثيره منها
الجزيره وغيرها يؤدي الى خلق راي معين هذا
هو الراي اللي عم نشوف نتيجته جميل لكن
واقع الامر بغض النظر عن الرقم الموجود
بعدين بحكي بالرقم لا شك انه اليوم القوه
الضاربه
للمعارضه السوريه العسكريه عم نحكي ا هي
جبهه النصره وهي باعتراف الجميع الجيش
الحر والجماعات الاسلاميه الاخرى التي
ذكرت انها تلعب دورا محوريا في مواجهه
السلطه فالقول ان لها دور مميز ليس لا
ياتي فقط من النظام بل ياتي من اعداء
النظام اعتراف جبهه النصره الذي حدث في
الاسبوع الماضي انها جزء من القاعده لم
ياتي من النظام بل جاء من المعارضه واليوم
دخلت المعارضه في خلاف مع جبهه النصره هي
تريد وجودها لا تريد وجودها لو انت عم
تقول مثل ما عم تقول 3000 ما كانوا
بيعملوا هفرق هي تصر على وجودها وتطالب
الامريكان وغيرها بازالتها عن لائحه
الارهاب لانه الامريكان وضعوها واليوم
اوروبا ستضع جبهه النصره على لائحه
الارهاب قريبا وبالتالي اذا لم يكن لها
هذا الدور المحوري لماذا تدافع الجميع
للدفاع عنها امام العالم الخارجي وفي
الداخل السوري اليوم جبه النصره ليست فقط
مؤلفه من خارجين من يعني قادمين من الخارج
بل اصبح جزء كبير منها من السوريين وهذا
الخطر الاكبر على الثوره نفسها مش بس على
النظام لذلك محاوله التخفيف وان عمليه لعب
اعلامي لا هو باعتراف الجميع انها لها دور
باعتراف الجميع وخاصه لنقول العالم الغربي
انها ارهابيه باعتراف معظم الانظمه
العربيه انها ارهابيه القاعده عم بحكي
وملحقاتها لذلك محاوله التخفيف من وجودها
ودورها واهميتها ولعب في الداخل السوري
هذا ااس وقال حتى يعني قال رئيس الائتلاف
وغيره انهم لا يشاركون جبهه النصره بايدي
لوجيات
لكنهم يقاتلون لنفس الهدف وهو اسقاط
النظام لكن بعد اسقاط النظام لكل منهم
مقاربه ومشروعه وهو على اخت لاف كبير فهو
فهم لا يمثلون الشعب السوري بالتاكيد
ولكنهم ايضا الان خطفوا الثوره من الثوار
خطفوا الثوره كيف ترد سمعت هذا الكلام
يعني الرجل يقول لك يعني نح لماذا هذا
التخفيف من العنصر الجهادي واتهام النظام
بانه يضخم يقول لك الرجل النظام ليس هو
الذي
يضخم المعارضه هي تتحدث عنها بهذا الشكل
امريكا تتحدث عنها بهذا الشكل اوروبا
تتحدث عنها بهذا الشكل فلماذا انتم
تحاولون التخفيف كيف ترد يعني انا الحقيقه
حينما اجلس امام الكتور مصلي وانا
احتر رجل يعني اتفرج على هذه اللغه
الهادئه التي يسوقها ويتكلم تضخيم اعلامي
وغير ذلك واعلم ان يعني للاسف الدكتور
موصلي يضع نفسه في موقف شبيحه بالوكاله
ليوصف الحاله هذا دليل على ان النظام
السوري لم يبقى في جعبته الا الذين
يدافعون عنه بهذه الطريقه التوصيف الثوره
تنتصر الرئيس معاذ الخطيب قال بالحرف قال
بالحرف الرئيس معاذ الخطيب ق اسمع دكتور
انا انا
اوصف انا اوصف لك
الحق على
السؤال انا اتكلم بصراحه الرئيس الرئيس
معاذ الخطيب قال بصراحه لم يكن هناك خلاف
في الراي او غير ذلك الرئيس معاد الخطيب
قال نحن لا يناسبنا فكر القاعده وهذا
الكلام ادى الى مراجعات داخل جبهه النصره
وتم انشاء مكتب سياسي ونحن نتامل ان يكون
لجبهه النصره دور سياسي واضح اما اكثر من
ذلك انه مبالغ بها يا اخي هل تريد ان تنكر
على السوريين ان 70 او 80% منهم مسلمون
يعني شو بدك الناس في سوريا تلبس بنتاكور
وتطلع تجاهد مع النظام هل تنظر الى يعني
لحيه السيد تبعك لحيه سيد المقاومه على
انها لحيه من ار لحيه حسن نصر الله هل
اصبحت هي لحيه الامن والامان والاطمئنان
ولحيه هؤلاء القوم الذين تنزل عليهم
الصواريخ 24 ساعه على انهم اناس جهاديون
يسوقون البلد ويختطفون الثوره هذه الثوره
صنعها شعب وهذا الشعب فيه تنوع وهذا
التنوع اخفاه النظام ولذلك نحن وصلنا الى
حاله يعبر بف الظام كيف اخفاه النظام
بالقتل وبما يفعل دكتور فيصل النظام منذ
البدايه احس ان الشعب السوري سيعود الى
جذوره الى بنيته الشعب السوري في التالي
شعب مؤمن شعب محافظ بمسيحي واسلامي النظام
الذي يصور لك الان على ان البلد بحاله
جهاد طيب انتم من البدايه ما مفتي النظام
دكتور احمد اعلن الجهاد ن انتم تبيتوا بال
البوطي احمد حسون اعلن الجهاد لنا قبل
ايام فرحتوا تبيتوا في البوطي وجدتوا فيه
وقبل فتره نظام تدافع عنه وانت تجلس الان
على كرسي المدافع عن ولك الشرف ان اردت او
ليس لك الشرف ان اردت يقول لك انه سيرسل
انتحاريين الى اوروبا جاءتنا البشائر وانا
لا اشكك ان اصابع النظام واضحه بما وعد به
مفتي النظام فيما جرى ببسط قبل ساعات
صديقي من يتكلم عن النظام السوري على ان
المعارضين اختطفوا الثوره من نظام نفسه
لسه عمو معترف في الثوره ويقول لك انها
انتهت ووصلنا الى مرحله اللا قلق
الاستراتيجي انا اقول لك هذه اللغه الهدي
التي تتكلم بها لا تعبر الا عن ان النظام
في رمقه الاخير وان جبهه النصره وغيرها من
الفصائل ليست الا جزء لا يتجزا من الثوره
السوريه مين هي الاجزاء الاخرى مثلا في من
الاقليات يعني يعني صديقي العزيز حينما
نصل الى ان ثلاثه قاده مجالس عسكريين
اعضاء في هيئه الاركان هم من الاخوه
المسيحيين ثلاثه ده مجالس عسكريه فاعله
وضباط يشهد لهم من الطائفه الدرزيه
الكريمه ضابطان رئيسيان في هيئه الاركان
من الاخوه الاسماعيليين هيئه اركان الجيش
الحر الجيش الذي انشق ابناؤه عن النظام
الجيش الذي يستدعي فيه قائد المجلس
العسكري بحلب العقيد عبد الجبار العقيدي
اي قائد عسكري من جبهه النصره واي قائد
عسكري من الكتائب الاسلاميه المقاتله
يستدعيهم الى مكتبه ويلقون السمع والطاعه
لان هذه الثوره رغم كل روف التحرير الصعبه
التي تنزل بها علينا الصواريخ في كل ساعه
وفي كل لحظه وتغتصب وتقتل فيها الاف مؤلفه
من السوريين ارواح تزهق رغم كل الشيء
استطعنا ان نبني بنيه دوله وان نبني بنيه
كيان لا ان يقول علي خضور قائد عمليات
الاجرام للنظام على التليفون لا استطيع ان
ارد لكم خبرا فيما افعل في الجرحى جرحاه
يقتلهم اما نحن فنحن ندير معركه باقل
الامكانيات لكن وكم من فئه قليله غلبت فئه
كبيره او كثيره باذن الله طيب سيد دكتور
مصلي المراسلون الميدانيون الذين جابوا
سوريا من شمالها الى جنوبها التقوا بكل
الفصائل المقاتله على الارض هذه احصائيه
اتيت بها قبل ان اتي يقولون نقابل 90 شخصا
او 95 شخص سوري غير متعصب لا علاقه له لا
بالنصر ولا بالقاعده ونقابل شخص غير سوري
او بعض الاشخاص الاسلاميين يقول لك انه
حتى انت تقول لي انه ليست عمليه عدد وانه
اقوى المقاتلين هم من جماعات الارهابيه
التي يلاحقها الغرب الان طيب لكن انا
لماذا لا اصدق هؤلاء اصدق هؤلاء المراسلين
الميدانيين الذين يقولون لك انه 90%
يتحدثون عن بعثيين يتحدثون عن مئات لا بل
الاف الطلاب السوريين الذين تركوا الدراسه
المحامين السوريين الاطباء الكذا الذين
تركوا عملهم ويقاتلون في الثوره السوريه
لماذا يتم التركيز على 2000 اوثلاثه ملتحي
وينسوا انه هذه ثوره شعب هذا اللي بدي
تجاوبني عليه نعم بس اول طبعا في نوع من
الاساءه
الشخصيه ل بك تسمحي اولا بتستعمل شبيح
واحد مثلك شبيح لان لا بشتغل عندك ولا عند
النظام السوري يا سيدي الكريم انا ادافع
قضيه شعب انا اتكلم هنا عن قضيه شعب انا
لم اصبيح ق
بالوكاله عنظام
شجل قلتلك ب مقاطعه دورك انتيد دكتور
سكتور سي دكتور شو بدك من الخاص المضوع
بدين
تمون عبدجليل ممنوع التجريح الشخصي تماما
دع الرجل يتكلم وارجوك تتكلمو ب ما في
تجريح جاوبني على سؤالي وانس الموضوع تفضل
ما في اسهل
من اليوم المعارضه السور نحن ما قنا
اسلاميه اسلامي ما حد عم يشكك بدين
الاسلامي دخل انه عمشك بالاسلام يعني بطرح
مواضيع اولا ما جاوبك على الامور اللي
طرحتها عليه هرب مننا لامور شخصيه اليوم
المعارضه السوريه تتشكل من عده تشكلات
اليوم المسيطر عليها بالقوه هذا اللي
حكيناه هذا المهم مش العدد 90 واحد مقابل
واحد واحد بيغلب 90 او بيفتح فيهم ما يد
اليوم الوضع الداخلي في سوريا يعني بس
دقيقه انت مشكلتك يعني انت مشكلتك مع انه
هذه الج جماعه قويه وتقاتل بقوه بس بدي
اسالك بدي اسالك عندك احد الزعماء
الصينيين له مقوله جميله يقول لك لا يهم
اذا كان او لا يهم اذا كان لون القط ابيض
او اسود طالما انه يصطاد الفئران وكذلك
ينطبق على المقاتلين يعني انا شو بهمني
اذا كان واحد عنده لحيه او ما عنده الا
اذا اذا يبي بلاء حسن على الارض بدي اسالك
بس بدي اسالك شو مشكلتكم مع هال
الاسلاميين هل تعلم ان ستالين هل تعلم ان
ستالين الملحد امر الشعب الروسي بان
يقرعوا اجراس الكنائس في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه كي يحفزهم دينيا ليش حلال على
السالين يستخدم الدين حرام على 80% من
السنه السوريين ما يقول لك لا اله الا
الله وال الله اكبر ترجع تخلط ما بين جبه
النص و السنه ككل ما هذا الموضوع بعدين
بدك تخليني احكي
يعنيي نحن اليوم ما عم نحكي على السني في
في سوريا عم تسالني عن فئه معينه ودورها
نحن ما عم نقول له دقن ما له د يصفي واححد
له د ولا له ك هي ذاتها ما عندي مشكله
الاساس اليوم النظره الاستراتيجيه للمنطقه
انه السوريا يريد قلب النظام من يريد قلب
النظام المشكله ما تريد القاعده ان تقوم
به ان تنشئ قاعده لها في بلاد الشام وان
تنطلق منه الى مشاريع اخرى لم تتمكن من
فعل ذلك في افغانستان لم تتمكن من فعل ذلك
في العراق الان تقوم بذلك في سوريا طبعا
المعارضه السوريه ستدافع عن جبهه النصره
لان ان بدونها لن يكون لها وجود عسكري
حقيقي فما عم نحكي عن مسلمين او غير
مسلمين عم نحكي على فئه معينه من الناس
لها فكر يكفر مش بس يعني النصره مصلحه
استراتيجيه للمعارضه
طبعا المشكله مع القاعده ليست انها مسلمين
او غيرها لا انها تكفر المسلم الاخر السني
الاخر تسمح لنفسها بضرب الاقليات تذبح الا
ط ما عندها روادع لا اخلاقيه ولا فكريه
ولا شيء هي اللي عم نحكي هل السوري يعني
عم نقول النظام الشعب السوري يريد ان
يستبدل نظام الاسد بنظام القاعده هذا هو
المطلوب اليوم في محاوله اخفاء لما يجري
في سوريا اليوم من يسيطر على الوضع مثلا
بحلب وادلب هن شو اسمه جبهه النصره مش
الجيش الحطيني دليل عكسه اطين دليل
عس
فيما لا تعرف انت تتكلم
بكلام انت تتكلم بكلام انشائ
يسيطرون سيد بس يجي دورك بس بس دقيقه انت
تقوللي يكفرون كذا طيب انا بدي اسالك انا
اصدقك انت اللي جاي من لبنان ولا اصدق
ميشيل كيلو الذي ذهب الى كل هذه الجماعات
ورجع يقول شعرا فيها ميشيل المسيحي بصدقك
ولا بصدقه بصدقك ولا بصدق جورج صبره جورج
طيب يعني يا اخي يعني ل لك شو انا لست
جزءا من الصراع هذ
المشكله جورج او غيره او الاستاذ هن جزء
من الصراع انا انسان عم بنظر للواقع
السوري وما يجري فيه وعم بحاول وصفه انا
لا اطلى وجهر النظام دقيقه بس دقيقه بدون
مظام سح ما عمك لا خليه كمل خليه يكمل
الرجل عنده
و شكلك ما بقدر يحدد المواضيع تل فموضوع
اجابه النص هي المشكله عم نحكي عنها ما عم
نحكي عن المعارضه ككل هل يريد السوري ان
يستبدل النظام بالقاعده رائع جدا خليك
عندي هذا سؤال في غايه الاهميه وارجوك
تجاوب عليه وما تلف ماشي ما تلف الرجل قال
كلاما واح زائد واحد يساوي اين اريدك ان
ترد عليه بهذه الطريقه يقول لك اه يقول لك
انه ليست المشكله مشكله مع ملتحين او غير
ملتحين او كذا او كذا يقول لك انه هذه
تعادي الاقليات احكي لي الان كيف تعادي
الاقليات يقول لك تخوف الاقليات كيف هي
والنظام انا دكتور راح جاوبك بس جاوبني ما
تروحش بعيد راح جاوبك وركز دكتور انه عم
بجاوب ركز روبرت كيسي سيناتور امريكي من
الذي صنف جبهه النصره على قائمه الارهاب
حتى الان والدكتور عم يبشرنا انه بعد ايام
كمان
اوروبا روبرت كيسي سيناتور امريكي التقيته
قبل ايام وكان في زياره لتركيا وطلبني
وطلب ناشط سوري قال لي بالحرف ان التقارير
التي وصلتهم عن ان جبهه النصره قوامها من
الاشخاص غير السوريين كانت تقارير مضلله
للاداره الامريكيه هذا الامريكي هذا كلام
السيناتور روبرت كيسي و على الاعلام
واذكره على الاعلام اكثر من ذلك قال
الامريكان انفسهم اصحاب القرار والسفير
الامريكي اعترف وحتى هذا مسجل على القنوات
الاعلاميه ان بعض الدول الحليفه لهم والتي
اكتشفوا وان تقاريرها تاتي من المخابرات
السوريه ضلتهم بوضع جبهه النصره وان
غالبيه ابناء جبهه النصره هم من سواد
الشعب السوري وانهم اشخاص لا يحملون فكر
القاعده وانهم اشخاص في التالي يقاتلون
وهذا جواب واضح الامريكان يعترفون اكثر من
ذلك اذا كان ابو محمد الجولاني قد احال
الامر الى تنظيم القاعده ثم في اليوم
الثاني قيادات جبهه النصره تجتمع في حلب
وفي ادلب وفي الرقه وحتى الرقه التي
راهنوا على ان تعلن اماره اسلاميه صر ل
الييوم حرر اكثر من شهرين هل سمعتم باماره
اسلاميه دكتور بعدين بدي اسالك سؤال
دكتورنا وخذني كما يقال بصدرك الحنون تؤمن
بالقضاء اللبناني بتحترم القضاء اللبناني
سؤال بتحترم القضاء اللبناني ما عندي جواب
طيب انت ما عندك جواب لشيء طيب القضاء
اللبناني يقول لك نظام بشار الاسد نظام
ارهابي وبعت لكم علي مملوك مع اسمع هذا
كلامك في القضاء اللبناني طيب يا صديقي
انت تقول لموقع توب نيوز ب
28 لحظه لحظه لا دكتور من ضمن الموضوع من
ضمن الموضع الرجل الرجل معلش هو انت تركت
له حق الرد وهو يتهمني باني لا اجيب انا
اريد ان اثبت له برده الاعصاب التي لا
تعنيه الرجل متفرج اما انا صاحب قضيه شعب
انا جاي من شعب 30 طفل قبل دقائق قتلوا
طيب انت تقول كل القوى الاسلاميه التي
تحاول الوصول للسلطه في العالم همها ان
ترضي الكيان الصهيوني طيب بدي اسالك طيب
بدي اسالك لماذا يحارب لا لا هذا كلامك
بتوب نيوز ب 28 ع تووب نيوز وما ادراك ما
توب نيوز ناصر قنديل ومسرحيه الف ليله
وليله اصدقائك جماعتك اسمع يا اخي اسمع يا
رجل اسمع ولا تقاطع اسمع ولا تقاطع اسمع
ولا تقاطع اسمع ولا تقاطع لو ما عندك انش
ما جابوك الامريكان اسمعوا ولا تقا تفضل
يا رجل هذا هذا السيد يقول هذا السيد يقول
انه جماعه القوى الاسلاميه التي تصل الى
السلطه كلها بدها رضا اسرائيل طيب النظام
السوري ليش عم يحارب جبه النصره لانها لا
تريد رضا اسرائيل جاوبني وتفضل لانه يعرف
ان جبه النصره لا ترضى عن اسرائيل الاقل
يقوللك تخوف الاقليات من الذي يقتل
الاقليات من الذ خوف الاقليات للرجل
دكتورنا الغالي النظام الذي صنع من ضريح
السلطان باشا الاطرش مزبله على مدار 27
سنه 2 77 سنه وضريح سلطان باشا الاطرش
مزبله في سوريا النظام الذي يسجن حتى الان
نائب الرئيس السوري شبلي العيسمي النظام
الذي حتى طائفته اذلها انا اشهد بام عيني
ان ضابطا واعتذر علويا اعتقل لانه كان يضع
صوره صالح العلي رحمه الله في مكتبه هذا
النظام الذي اذل دكتور هذا النظام الذي
اذل كل السوريين بكل بمختلف
طوائفهم يا اخي في عهد حفظ اسد كم لما
استلم حفظ اسد السلطه كم كان عهد
المسيحيين مليونين ونص مسيحي كان في سوريا
في عهد حافظ اسد لم يبقى منهم الا مليون
ونص في عهد بشار الان لا يوجد من
المسيحيين باعتراف البطرك البطرك تبعك في
لبنان اللي عامل سفير البطرك نفسه يعترف
انه لم يبقى غير 800 الف مسيحي نظام
البعث نظام البعث هجر المسيحيين وهجر
طائفته نفسها وسيه جر من ايام الجيش الحر
يحمي علويين يهربون اليه في سهل الغاب من
ايام الجيش الحر يحمي اسماعيليين يهربون
اليه في ريف حماه من السلميه هذا هو الجيش
الحر هذا جيش بلادي هذا جيش المستقبل طيب
بس انت قلتها في في البدايه انه هو الذي
يصنع هذه الجماعات من يصدق هذا الكلام طيب
سؤال دكتور مين الذي صنع لنا ابو عدس مين
اللي صنعنا ابو عدس انت مو في عندك فيديو
وهذا زعيم لبناني عندك زعيم بلدك من الذي
صنع من ال صنع لنا ابو القاق مين اللي قال
وتحدث عن ان شوف الاعلام السوري حتى دكتور
وهذه ملاحظه فنيه الاعلام السوري حينما
يذكر اي مقاتل ينسبه الى الجيش الحر يسميه
بالمدعو ولما بده يمشي لنا اسطوانه جبهه
النصره دائما يسميهم الارهابي فلان
الارهابي فلان اذا الامر مدروس بدقه
ومدروس عالي المستوى كيف طيب مثلا وين
صنعهم وين صنعهم يعني باختر اخ كيف يعني
هناك استديوهات السيد علي مملوك للانتاج
والتوزيع الامني نظام خبير يا اخي اذا
مستشارين من ه النموذج
ا طيب الم يقل طيب اسمع الم يقل الم يقل
التائب عمليات الخطف يعني النظام وراها يا
اخي دقيقه دكتور دكتور ل اخ هناك عمل خط
اقول اقول لك يا اخي جاوبني على هذه اقول
لك النظام الذي اصبح الان جل مستشارين من
ايران ونحن نتكلم في هذه اللحظات والشيعه
والشيعه يهجرون الناس في بصره الشام
والنظام يصنع في فروعه الامن العسكري في
درعا شبيحه وشخصيات امنيه كالخليل وغيره
ليخطفوا اخواننا الدروس في سويدا يا رجل
دكتور منذ ايام النظام يصنع ناس كما
يريدهم يرسلهم الى السويداء يختطف ناس
ويقول لهم من جبهه النصرا الم يتذكر الناس
الخليل الذي اكتشف فيما بعد انه موظف امن
دوله الم يكتشف الناس ال هذا اليلي
الخليلي رجل دين ظهر علينا في درعا والناس
تعرفه عبد السلام الخليلي ظهر علينا على
انه رجل دين في درعا ثم قالوا لنا ان هذا
رجل الدين يسب نساء اخواننا في الطائفه
الدرزيه بعد ذلك كله يكتشف بان هذا الرجل
اخوه موظف امني معروف في امن الدوله و
وبعد ذلك كله يكتشف انه موظف امن دوله
موظف امن دوله خليني بس اقول لك فكره
اخيره الم الم يخرج علينا الباكستانيون في
شوارع حمص وينهم الباكستانيين الم يخرج
علينا رجالات سهيل الحمد ومحرز ابراهيم
حمد وغيره من جماعه سهيل الحسن ال الم
يخرجوا علينا في شوارع حمص ان القاعده
ملات حمص هذا الكلام من حوالي 19 سنه
وفيما بعد اين اكتشفنا ا اين جبه النصره
في حمص الان اين جبه النصره في حماء اين
جبه النصره في حلب اذا كنا في الائتلاف
الوطني والمجالس المحل والمجلس الوطني لا
يوجد اي عنصر من جبهه النصره حراك مدني
خالص حراك مدني خالص ورغم كل ه الشيء وسجل
عندك دكتور نحن في ظل الثوره وفي فتره
التحرير والصواريخ تنزل علينا ونحن نعيب
على جبهه النصره بعض المواقف بينما النظام
الذي يسبح بحمد اسرائيل لم يستطع ان يرد
على رامي مخلوف حين قال امن سوريا من امن
اسرائيل دكتور موصلي نعود الى قوه هذه
الجماعات وهي كما قلت انت قبل قليل بانها
ال ال ال المقدمه الاستراتيجيه للمعارضه
ولا لا ماشي طيب انا بدي اسالك سوريا
منتفض من اقصاها الى اقصاها من حلب من ريف
حلب حتى حدود الاردن مساحه سوريا 185000
كيلو هل يعقل هل يمكن ان نصدق ان 3000
مقاتل من النصره يا سيدي و 50 واحد من
تونس و14 من الباكستان و16 من بوركينا
فاسو و18 من فرق بقلق كلياتهم هذول مضبطين
كل سوريا يعني 4000 بيغطوا هال الجبهه
السوريه الكبيره جاوبني انت انت محلل
وخبير اولا طلبت منك تطلب منه ما يعمل
ملاحظات شخصيه رجع عمل كذا ملاحظ بدك
تسمحلي رد ماصير شو الملاحظه الشخصيه شو
الملاحظه الشخصيه يا رجل والله شو بدك
بالملاحظه الشخصيه والله مش م قيمه في
عالم اخر جاوبني عليها شو بدك فيها يا
زلمه انت اكبر مننا اصلا انا اتكلم عن
قضيه شعبي انا اتكلم عن من يقتلون انا
اتكلم عن نساء تغتصب انا اتكلم عن ماذن
تقصف انا اتكلم
اتم
عن
ينن الء
بلد قضاء بلدك لا ترد عل
تع
انس اسكت ارجوك سيد يا دكتور احمدم دكتور
احمد يا اخي خلص خلص يا زلمه دكتور احمد
انت استاذ جامعه كبير يا
زلمه يا عبد الجليل بطلنا نع يا عبد
الجليل خلينا نكمل الحلقه لكن الحلقه اهم
من هذا الكلام دكتور
احمد دكتور احمد دكتور كبير انت دكتور
كبير جاوبني على هذه النقطه بس بدي اسالك
بدي اسالك انا سالتك جميل جميل كويس
التقديرات الاجنبيه الامريكيه والمراكز
الابحاث كلها ودراسات المخابرات
والاستراتيجيه يا اخي خلكم بدون مقاط ه
بوست بتعرفوا
ايضل اجتمع مع يا عبد الجليل تفضل تفضل خي
اليوم التقديرات العلميه بكل مراكز
الابحاث بين 20 و25 هيدا مش بس العدد عم
نحكي العدد اليوم جبهه النصره تستقطب
وتاخذ من المجموعات الثانيه جميل وهي الى
ازدياد يعني مع انتهاء النظام اذا قدروا
ينهوا النظام انا بعتقد ما ح يقدروا
الامور تتغير على اي حال لن يكون
بقدره السوريين ان يقيموا النظام المدني
الديمقراطي الحر الذي يريدونه خليني اسال
نص سؤال نص نص سؤال كلامك جميل جدا انه
هؤلاء سيمنعون السوريين من بناء النظام
الذي يريدونه هو مش هذا كلامك طيب انا
اقول لك معلومه معلومه والايام بيننا لو
سالت كل المجاهدين بين قوسين مشان ما
تحسبني لا هون ولا هون في سوريا الان ماذا
ستفعلون فيما لو سقط النظام يقولون لك لن
نبقى لحظه واحده في سوريا لانه لدينا
مهمات جهاديه في مناطق اخرى والايام جايه
على كل حال بدي اسالك سؤال استاذ احمد انت
مش استاذ علوم سياسيه نعم طيب
بربك هل يمكن انت انت الانسان الكبير
والمفكر تصدق لي انه ثلاث الاف 4 الاف
و2000 يستطيع ان يقودوا بلدا عظيما يقود
دمشق انت تعلم دمشق في في تاريخها كله ما
هي دمشق بلد حاضره التجاره حاضره الاقتصاد
الانسان الدمشقي يصلي ثم يذهب الى عمله
اسلام معتدل لا يمكن ان يقبل لا يمكن ان
يقبل متطرفين حلب ام الاكل والشرب والفن
لا تقبل ب متطرفين غالبيه الشعب السوري
سوق الحمديه لو لم ياتي اليه المسيحي
والشيعي والدرزي والعلوي والسني والكل لا
يمكن ان يشتغل ليس هناك مكان لهؤلاء في
سوريا فلا تخوفون فيهم والاقليات ما
بتقبلهم فما عاد تقوللي اياهم بعدين ما
راح يظلوا بسوريا اذا ظلوا طيب بتشارط انه
ما را يظلوا بسوريا خليني ليش تخفو فيهم
يا اخي اليوم التيار الاسلامي العام هو
تيار معتدل مش هذا الموضوع بس عم نقول انه
هذا الاخوان بدون مقاطعه بدون انا مع
الشعب السوري يحكم حال مش مع تنظيم انا
راي انه عموم الاسلام السوري معتدل معروف
وعم نشكك فيه ولكن الان الامور تنسحب الى
سياق اخر مع وجود هالمجموعه القوه الضاربه
لهذا الجيش انا اللي عم اقوله انه على
اليوم العالم الغربي سينقلب على المعارضه
حتى لو شاف السناتور وحكي معه وحكي مع
السفير هذا لا ينفع في القرار قرار بتاخذه
وكالات المخابرات والخارجيه والدفاع
والرئيس طبعا الامريكي وهم على طريق
الانقلاب على المعارضه وخاصه انه ما تنسى
انه حتى اليوم لم يتم دعم المعارضه بالشكل
الحقيقي المطلوب لتغيير النظام اذا كان
هناك قرار عالمي بتغيير النظام ليس هناك
ما يحدث الان هو ان الامور ت تنهار وتدهور
في الداخل السوري وهي الى على يعني اليوم
وجود واعتراف جبهه النصر بانها ملحقه
بالقاعده او جزء من القاعده سيؤثر على
المعارضه بشكل كبير انا كل اللي كنت عم
اقوله بالاساس الفكره العامه ا انه هؤلاء
يجب ان لا يكونوا راس حربه التغير وانه
الامور قادمه على على يعني لا شك انه
الامور ستدفع باتجاه قرار سياسي وليس حسم
عسكري وبالتالي وجود هال الجماعه وعم تقوى
كل يوم بيوم يعني اليوم وصلت الى حد انها
تسيطر على المعاه المعارضه المسلحه على
الارض مش على القرار السياسي للمعارضه
جميل طيب كويس جدا طيب سيد كيف ترد على
هذا الكلام الرجل يحكي منطق الرجل مفكر
سياسي الرجل دكتور في السياسه ويتكلم من
منطق وليس من انشائي وليس من عواطف وليس
من كل هذا الكلام يقول لك الرجل انه
حاجتنا عاد نقول قال لي فلان وقل لي علان
وقل لي كذا هؤلاء اصبحوا يشكلون خطرا على
سوريا طيب بدي اسالك الا يستطيع النظام
السوري الان ومن حقه ان يقول لك ايها
العالم قلت لكم ان سوريا ليس فيها ثوره بل
فيها نظام وطني يقاوم جماعات ارهابيه الان
يقول لك النظام هذا الكلام يتبين عن الارض
على الارض خاصه بعد تحالف تحالف النصره مع
مع القاعده كيف ترد عليه للرجل الحقيقه
لوي اعناق النصوص لوي اعناق النصوص نا
والتوبه التي يظهرها الدكتور حرص على
السوريين الحرص على السوريين الحرص على
السوريين وان المعارضه لهذه المسلحه تسيطر
على الوضع وغير ذلك انا ابشر الدكتور اذا
كان كثير اكلين هم السورين هم مع الشعب
السوري ابشر الدكتور بان السوريين انفسهم
لا يكتبون على صفحاتهم كما قال نضال عيس
اليوم انه امريكا تدفع ثمن وقوفها مع
الثوره السوريه وتدفع ثمن وقوفه ضد النظام
السوري نحن يا جماعه نحن يا جماعه اولا لا
نتكلم بهذه اللغه ومشاهد القتل والدم بنظر
نضال ن عيسه
تنتشر صديقي نحن شعب ينشد حريته وهذا
النظام نحن من صبرنا شو قصد شو قصدك بهذا
الك يعني انه النظام السوري الان النظام
السوري هو له اصابع مثل ما بيقول الاخ بده
يورط جماعته نضال بده يورط جماعته عم
بيقول انه النظام السوري النظام السوري هو
اللي عم يشتغل ببوسطن قال مشاهد القتل
والدم تنتشر في بوستن بعد ان انتقلت
المعركه الى هناك هذا كلام على كل وبشر
الدكتور حتى ما يخاف علينا كثير نحن شعب
صبر على هذا النظام وها نحن الان نزيله
بايدينا ثلاث ارباع اللي عم يحكي عنهم
الدكتور انهم دخلوا واجوا وراحوا هم اشخاص
فاتوا من بالاساس دكتور للاغاثه وفيما بعد
لما راوا هذا الشعب يقتل ويذبح وقفوا معه
اكثر من ذلك ازك خاف على سوريا من هؤلاء
الرجل يحذر ازيدك من الشعر ازيدك من الشعر
بيتا لا اخاف على سوريا من هؤلاء لسبب
واحد لانهم من ابناء سوريا وهم ادرى
بمصلحه سوريا حينما انتجنا مجلسا محليا في
مدينه حلب شهد له العالم لم يصل الى سده
ذلك المجلس او في اركانه او في حدائقه او
في اطرافه اي متطرف كما يزعم العالم جبهه
النصره نفسها انا شهدت محكمه لجبهه النصره
في احدى المناطق الم حرره وهي تقول لرجل
سب جورد صبره على المنبر تحاسبه وتفصله عن
الخطابه اربعه جمعه انا لا امجد هنا لجبهه
ال وماذا تقول عن اذا ما رايك بهذه
الشيطنه والتخويف للعالم الخارجي ولاقل من
من من القاعده ومن جماعات ك شو تفس طيب
النظام يستعمل ضدنا مقدرات دوله البلد
كلها تحت ايده مقدرات بلد كامل تحت ايده
وحينما نصل نحن للسلطه في مدينه الرقه
نستدعي المجلس المحلي ونفرض عليه من
المكونات المسيحيين بل وحتى الشي انا اقول
حتى لاهلنا في القرداحه والله من سيحمي في
اخر الساعات هو الجيش السوري الحر وهو
الكتائب الاسلاميه اقول حتى لاهلنا في
مختلف سوريا وليس كلاما انشائيا وسنشهد من
سيحمي ليس النظام الذي يطمئن اليه بعض
قادتكم لواء ابو الفضل العباس يعني مو
متطرف وجبهه النصره صارت متطرفه
ح حزب الله الذي يشيع كل دقائق اناسا قضوا
في واجب جهادي هدول ناس جايين يدافعوا
الاف مؤلفه من حزب الله ومن مرتزقه ايران
دخلت الى سوريا وتدخل طيب هذول ليش ما
يتحدث عنهم الدكتور اليسوا هؤلاء يا دكتور
احمد عبا ايضا على الشعب السوري اليس الاف
من حزب الله بالله عليك وانت تتحدث كدكتور
جامعه وعلى عيني وراسي يا استاذ العلوم
السياسيه اليس الاف مؤلفه من حزب الله
والاف مؤلفه من مرتزقه ايران ولا تقول لي
كلام انشائي كلام هيومن رايتس وتش بتامن ف
ولا ما بتامن فيها هيوم الراس وش بتقول لك
في تاريخ 13/1 20113 ان جماعات مرتزقه
شهدت وتعمل وتغتصب في شتى المناطق
المحاصره بحمص بحمص وبيف حماء وبيف دمشق
طيب اكثر من ذلك الايرانيين الذين تم
تبادل الاسرى بهم شو كانوا عم يتنزه عم
يتنزه بصر الشام التي تدك في هذه اللحظات
دكتور من قبل الجماعات الشيعيه التابعه
لحزب الله اقول لاخواننا في لبنان وانقل
رساله للبنانيين عني اقول لاخواننا
المتورطين الان والناظرين الى غياهب
الامور والله لا يفرقنا في لبنان قالها في
يوم من الايام مقبور قالها شعب واحد في
دوله نحن نقول لسنا ايضا شعب واحد في
دولتين نحن في الاساس منبع واحد منهج واحد
من قتل كمال جنبلاط في لبنان ومن قتل جورج
حاوي في لبنان ومن قتل زعماء الاقليات ليس
مطمئنا للمسيحيين ولا للدروز اليوم هذا
يطمئن فقط القتل الذين صنعهم اما الجيش
الحر الذي يتعامل مع الجميع ويتشاور مع
الجميع المعارضه السياسيه التي تلتقي مع
الدرزي وتعترف بالسني وتعترف بالعلوي
وتعترف بالجميع نحن نضم بناء دوله مدنيه
وارجع واستشهد لك يا دكتور حتى لا يدخلك
الخوف على مصير سوريا دكتورنا نحن نخرج من
المساجد وننادي بالحريه بدك احسن من هيك
يعني ما تم غير الاسير اللي راح يعمل اسكي
عنكم بفاريا نحن شو بدك احسن من هيك شو
بدك انت تطمئن للنظام واريد منك موقف واضح
بالله عليك رايك بمجموعات حزب الله التي
دخلت واسمح لي ان اوجه لك هذا السؤال
دكتور سمعت هذا الكلام بدك تجاوبني عليها
قبل ايام عرضوا جوازات سفر ايرانيه الى
الجنه ايراني يقاتلون في الرقه يقاتلون في
اكثر من مكان ومعهم جوازات سفر ايرانيه
معطيهم اياها خامنئي روحوا اقتلوا
السوريين وعلى الجنه فورا وهذه الجوازات
موجوده السؤال الاخر السؤال الاخر طيب حزب
الله حزب الله يعلنها الان طيب لماذا
الجماعات الجهاديه السنيه في سوريا
ارهابيه وجماعه حزب الله والحرس الثوري
الايراني والعراقي وهم بالالاف الذين
يذبحون السوريين ليش ما حد عم يحكي عنهم
بالله ليش هالتركيز على لا واحد من
القاعده اذا كانوا موجودين ونسيان يعني
بالله حسن نصر الله وجماعه حزب الله
وايران هذول عسل حملان وديعه كما يقول لك
الرجل انا ما لي علاقه تفضل طيب لا طبعا
انت لك علاقه بس الي علاقه بدي اسال طبعا
ط لا اكثر طبعا انا بخصب يور بخصب
يورانيوم نباتي لا تخاف تخصب يورانيوم ليه
ممنوع تخصيب اليورانيوم نباتي بس هجموا
اسرائيل مل ما تجمير على فكره القاعده ما
بتجم الده صحب ما بتهاجم
القاعده ما بتهاجم
اسرائيل لا لا تخاف القاع خلب في سؤال
للرجل خليه ي جاوب
افضل يمع ولا يس المهم شوف اليوم الدوله
السوريه عندها حلفاء ومن حلفاء ايران وحزب
الله وما في شي مخبى المعارك اللي عم تصير
هي بالمناطق الحدوديه في الاغلب بالغالب
هلا في مساعدات للسلطه في يعني هي دوله
على اي اساس يحال الدوله حزب جماعه
ارهابيه اي اس اس انا اس اس خل جامي ولا
تحترم سؤال حزب حزب وجماعه كيف
بحال يا سيدي اخذت كلامك رجاء تكون
ديمقراطي رجاء خلي الرجل يتكلم تفضل
جامعات متحالفين مع دول تبدا من محل ولا
تنتهي ومع
تف النظام السوري الجديد تفضل تفضل شاء
الله ذكرك بعد
سنهما المهم انه قضيه حزب الله حزب الله
وسوريا وايران مرتبطين
بتع اليوم التحالف المقابل يدخل في
الجماعات الاسميه الاخوان المسلمين
القاعده حتى اسرائيل حتى الدول الغربيه
حتى مخابرات اجنبيه اليوم في حرب
استراتيجيه على المطقه طيب بس بدي اسالك
كيف امريكا كيف امريكا كيف امريكا بتدعم
النصره كيف امريكا بتدعم النصره وبتحط على
تدعم الصره الولايات المتحده رفضت من زمان
دعمهم لكن عبر قنوات انيه تدعم الاخوان
المسلمين اليوم بمصر من يدعم الاخوان
المسلمين مين يدعم الاخوان المسلمين وفي
دول خليجيه تدعم
السلفيين الاخوان تدعمهم قطر تركيا ودول
اخرى اليوم في هذا التصغير للوضع في سوريا
ام هو تصغير لواقع المر للمنطقه كلها
المنطقه على فوهه بركان وتغير وستتغير
عده لذلك اليوم القول انه في مجموعه
بتحارب هون او مجموعه تحارب هون انا ما
عندي مشكل مشكله انه هناك من ياتي ويقاتل
في سوريا سواء مع المعارضه او مع الدوله
انا معي مع المشروع السياسي لمستقبل سوريا
وليست على وجود اجانب في الدا رائع جدا
كيف ترد على هذه الكلمه الرجل يقول لك هو
اصلا ضد كل اي جماعه تدخل سوريا كانت من
اي مكان وه كلام منطق هو يخشى على مستقبل
سوريا السوريون لم يتحركوا لم يطالبوا
بالاصلاح والتغيير كي ينتقلوا من السيء
الى الاسوا هذا هو كلامك ولا لا تفضل
انبسطت هلا ممنون مين الرجل بالموضوع اول
شيء بنص دقيقه بربع انتهى الوقت طيب انا
اريد ان اقول كلمه بالاخر انتهى معك ربع
دقيقه يد ان اقول كلمه دكتور ماذا تقول
للشعب السوري اريد ان اقول كلمه ان الشعب
السوري الذي يقول بثوره شعبيه استطاع من
خلالها ان يزيل فروع ارهاب كامله بنيت على
تصنيع الارهاب حتى في اقبيه المخابرات
السوريه حتى تنتج امثال هؤلاء ليدافعوا
عنها وصل الى درجه يعبر فيها عن ان النظام
انتهى وانه لم يبقى في جعبتهم الا الشتائم
سلملي على جماعتك وقل لهم تلمسوا رؤوسكم
الجيش الحر سيدوس الى
اللقاء i